vous avez été victime de ces thérapies
de conversion dont on va expliquer le
détail et je voudrais revenir en arrière
à votre enfance vous éprouvez vous êtes
une famille catholique vous éprouvez une
attirance pour les garçons qu'est ce qui
se passe à ce moment là dans votre
famille comment c'est reçu alors ma
famille est une famille savoyarde comme
il y en avait beaucoup il ya encore une
cinquantaine d'années dans beaucoup de
régions de france enraciné sur une terre
et enracinés dans la foi catholique mais
elle n'a rien d'une famille
traditionaliste encore moins intégristes
mais elle nous propose à ma soeur et à
moi même une éducation chrétienne avec
le catéchisme la messe dominicale
et moi je j'ai une inclination que je
qualifierais naturel j'aime être dans
les églises j'aime me rendre à la messe
j'aime prier j'aime retrouver des
religieuses dans ma paroisse et je suis
attirée depuis tout petit aussi loin que
ma mémoire ne me fait pas défaut par le
visage du christ non pas que je les vues
ou qu'ils aient entendu rassurez vous
mais je suis très attiré par son
innocence chaque fois qu'on me parle de
lui c'est le fait que c'est un homme
finalement qui gardent un coeur d'enfant
jusqu'au bout et ça ça m'attire ça me
fascine quelque part ça me séduit et
dans un même temps je découvre que je
suis aussi fascinée par la beauté du
corps des hommes dans ma petite ville
natale d'albertville qui à l'époque où
j'étais enfant avait à peu près dix sept
mille habitants les seules grandes
sorties pour les visas les villages
environnants et pour la ville c'était
les fêtes foraines donc on se rendait à
la fête foraine avec ma famille et moi
je regardais les hommes je regardais la
beauté des torse velu sur des chemises
ouvertes les pantalons moulants
j'aimerais bien ouais ouais ouais c'est
bah c'était là notre style que le christ
oui c'est c'était mike brant quoi
ce sujet on en a on n'a pas du tout
autant du clean et ça correspond à
l'opposé aux bâillements voilà ceci dit
ceci dit je sens parce que parce qu'il
ya une petite une collision entre no cry
nation sexuelle disons et puis il veut
pas l'or sexuelle dirais pas ça quand
j'étais enfant parce que non mais après
on ne parlait pas dans les années 70
d'homosexualité albertville où aussi on
en parlait c'était pour dire des choses
très glauque c'était pour parler d'un de
mes cousins que ces expatriés qui avait
semble-t-il des moeurs à part comme on
disait dans les repas de famille et donc
moi j'ai senti assez vite dans ma petite
tête de gamin qu'il fallait que je t'ai
cette partie de moi même et je crois que
je suis entré progressivement dans une
dans un processus de honte qui a qui m'a
fait entrer dans un mutisme
il fallait que je t'ai cela et pour le
ter au mieux j'ai compris aussi qu'il
fallait mettre le turbo sur la dimension
spirituelle et je me suis n'ont pas
inventé mais en tout cas j'ai mis le
turbo encore une fois sur le personnage
spirituelle qui était le mien le futur
petit curé le futur moines et jeu
donnait le change quelque part parce que
parce que j'avais tous les ingrédients
d'un turbo mais vous étiez quand même
croyance et paris ne simule pas non je
ne simulait pas j'étais je pense très
sincère mais je pense que c'était aussi
dans ma tête je le redis comme ça avec
des années de recul une manière aussi de
me dire ben j'aurais pas justifier un
célibat je n'aurais pas justifié que je
suis attiré par les garçons si je
deviens religieux ou prêtres et tout
doucement c'est
s'est ancré en moi comme une une double
personnalité alors ça s'est pas fait du
jour au lendemain mais ça a commencé
dans mon enfance et puis ça s'est
poursuivi au collège au collège où j'ai
vécu une expérience que je ne pensais
pas vivre parce que à l'école primaire
c'était relativement paisible mais quand
je suis arrivé au collège j'ai vécu ce
que l'on n'appelait pas à mon époque
mais que l'on appelle aujourd'hui le
harcèlement c'est à dire que j'ai vécu
la méchanceté gratuite la haine gratuite
alors il n'y avait pas à mon époque bien
évidemment les réseaux sociaux mais les
insultes étaient les mêmes je trouvais
sur la selle de mon vélo tagué à la
craie [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] et quand
c'était pas ça c'était sur mon cartable
et puis ces mots bain mouillés j'ai 56
ans depuis l'été dernier sont restés
ancrés dans ma tête parce que la
violence elle commence par les mots et
j'étais tétanisée parfois sur la cour de
mon collège j'évitais les groupes
d'hommes et harceleurs et tout doucement
ça m'a fait perdre beaucoup d'estimé de
moi de confiance en moi et ça m'a encore
plus invité à entrer dans la honte la
honte ça ça nous claque mur vivant dans
une tombe c'est une expérience de
morts-vivants finalement mais tout ce
que vous venez de dire qu'est ce que ça
devient dans un cadre strictement
religieux quand vous devenez religieux
que devient cette question homosexuelle
comment elle est perçue par les autres
vous avez parlé de harcèlement dans le
cadre scolaire mais dans le cadre
religieux qu est ce que tout ça devient
jusqu'à mes 18 ans je n'en parle pas je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure j'étais entré
dans un mutisme la honte à tous
paralysés elle a paralysé ma parole et
je sentais comme par intuition qui
n'allait pas bien j'en parle parce que
si j'en parlais je risquais de ne pas
pouvoir devenir prêtre et puis j'avais
peur aussi de décevoir mes parents de
décevoir mais c'est moi monsieur mais
nous attendons ce témoignage est très
intéressant mais dans l'institution même
parce qu'on sait que à la fin du xixème
siècle au début xxème siècle une énorme
majorité de gens qui avaient ces mêmes
souffrances par rapport à leur identité
leurs familles sont allées dans l'église
précisément pour être préservé donc je
voulais savoir si à l'intérieur même de
l'institution ecclésiastique vous avez
pu en parler alors que dwayne le sol
alors pardon mes 18 ans monsieur
j'ai donc j'ai fait mes études
secondaires sans en parler en étant un
parfait petit croyants si je puis dire
en ayant de dimension spirituelle très
forte beaucoup de devis triaire une
inclination à une vie intérieure que
j'ai toujours d'ailleurs je ne dis pas
que je sais prier mais en tout cas
j'aime prier et à l'âge de 18 ans j'ai
quitté ma savoie natale pour montpellier
pour rejoindre un couvent de karm donc
une ordre très contemplatif je pense que
les frères qui m'ont accueilli l'ont
fait avec beaucoup de de générosité et
d'un certain réalisme aussi parce que
parce que je donnais le change encore
une fois seulement quand je suis arrivé
là loin de ma famille et bien tout mon
affectivité qui était totalement
immature est ressorti et puis ma
sexualité est devenu hyper compulsive il
faut quand même savoir que j'ai commencé
à vivre ma vie sexuelle dans des
endroits plus glauques les uns que les
autres dans les toilettes publiques de
la gare d'albertville dont s'était pas
les lieux les plus romantiques et puis
bon ma première expérience vraiment
c'était à 14 ans lors d'un pèlerinage à
lourdes où on m'avait laissé quelques
heures sol et où j'ai été abusé
sexuellement par un homme beaucoup plus
âgé que moi dans les toilettes qui se
trouve à deux pas de la grotte de
lourdes donc pour un jeune catholique
vous imaginez le tsunami que cela a
provoqué transgressif la traîtresse
winter je suis sorti de là j'étais
totalement liquide games est un peu plus
d'hommes d'église lorsqu'au bidon sujet
actuel a pas ma connaissance en tout cas
ils n'emportaient aucun signe extérieur
et quand je suis arrivé à montpellier
mais toute cette compulsivité parce que
ma sexualité elle était toujours
contenu en mois les sorties alors on
était au début des années 80 il y avait
encore très peu de lieux de drague gay
style sauna et tout cela mais il y avait
déjà des jardins publics comme le jardin
du peyrou il y avait des cinémas pornos
hétéros mais dans lequel se vivait des
rencontres au mot et moi je suis parti
là dedans et j'ai commencé à vivre un
malheureux là pour le coup un
écartèlement terrible et c'est là
monsieur que j'ai commencé à en parler
c'est à dire que je me suis ouvert à un
jeune frère de la communauté qui m'a
accueilli ça je ne peux pas dire que je
n'ai pas été accueilli seulement je me
méfie beaucoup aujourd'hui du mot
accueille au sein de l'église parce que
c'est un gargarisme bien souvent je
crois que l'on confond accueil et estime
estimer quelqu'un c'est beaucoup plus
profond que de l'accueillir et on ne m'a
pas estimé véritablement n'a pas estimé
ce que j'étais en train de vivre parce
que si on m'avait estimé eh bien on
aurait renvoyé en savoie pour reprendre
mes études pour reprendre une vie
familiale secure et c'est donc j'ai
continué et c'est là qu'on m'a proposé
une première prière de guérison on les
voit là jésus va te guérir de ton
homosexualité par la prière alors oui
j'étais on était dans dans la mouvance
du renouveau charismatique qui est un
mouvement qui est arrivé des etats-unis
du pentecôtisme américain dans le
catholicisme français et européens dans
les années 60 m en 6 ans quand on prie
dieu
être délivré de son homosexualité l'eau
plutôt guéri la première étape c'est un
petit groupe de prière sous les quelques
personnes qui demande à jésus
effectivement de vous guérir de ce qu'il
considère comme si ce n'est une maladie
mais en tout cas une blessure on insiste
beaucoup sur relation avec votre père
avec votre mère donc on vous conditionne
beaucoup dans le fait que votre
homosexualité est venue d'un problème
relationnel avec votre terre avec votre
mère et on demande à jésus de vous
guérir mais c'est resté assez light
seulement avec du recul et si finalement
depuis très peu de temps que je suis
sorti de ce déni traumatique je crois
que j'ai vécu un vrai traumatisme à 18
ans parce que c'est là qu'a commencé
cette emprise spirituel je crois que
j'ai commencé un formatage d'entrer dans
un formatage et un véritable rapt de mon
jeu et puis à partir de là j'ai quitté
le couvent parce que j'étais trop
immature et puis que ma sexualité était
occupé beaucoup trop mon corps restera
et on m'a proposé d'entrer dans un lieu
de formation qui à l'époque avait le
vent en poupe on formait des jeunes à ce
que l'on appelle l'évangélisation la
prière et là bas je suis tombé amoureux
d'un garçon de 7 de ce lieu jusque là je
m'était interdit c'était des plans cul
sans lendemain mais là c'était vraiment
un c'était vraiment un
sentiment aux profonds et ça m'a quelque
part obligé en parler au responsable de
ce lieu qui m'ont dit tu sais jean
michel je pense que tu as une
homosexualité structurelles c'est la
première fois que j'entendais cette
expression et si tu veux vraiment être
prêtre et bien c'est qu'elle soit
conjoncturelle à vous pouvez peut-être
mais en tout cas ce que ce que l'on
semaine l'actualité de la semaine ce
qu'on croit comprendre ce qu'est ce que
ce que l'on veut pour toi c'est que tu
sens soit délivré et on m'a proposé des
prélats de délivrance tant qu un cran au
dessus les prix y adeux de guérison que
j'avais vécu précédemment et ça a été
tout un processus finalement long
plusieurs prières de délivrance et là
vous vous entrez dans dans un petit
groupe qui prient sur vous comme on dit
dans ce milieu là ces qui vous imposent
les mains il ya des paroles de prophétie
c'est à dire des gens qui parlent au nom
de dieu on ouvre la bible un peu à
n'importe quelle page on vous dit que du
êtes en train de vous parler d'ailleurs
je fais une petite parenthèse mais vous
avez peut-être entendu le pré dans sauvé
qui a remis le rapport mardi dernier et
qui a préconisé dans ses préconisations
justement une vigilance par rapport à
passer sur les abus sexuels commis là
représentants de l'élite qu'ils soient
religieux il y là il a préconisé une
vigilance surtout c'est cette dimension
des charismes où des gens si vous voulez
se se situe
dans une posture où il parle au nom de
dieu mais quand vous avez 18 19 ans
comme c'était mon cas pris dans cette
ambiance dans cette émotion je pense pas
que ce soit un scoop ce soir de dire ici
que je suis hyper sensible tous les gens
qui me connaissent le savent donc
j'étais encore plus à l'époque j'avais
beaucoup de mal à
aborder ma sensibilité mon émotionnel et
ces gens là jouent beaucoup là dessus
sur l'émotionnel voilà alors décrit deux
stades quel a été le stade iii si j'ose
dire et je pose une question oui bien
sûr à partir du moment où vous dis
prière de guérison prière de délivrance
qu'est ce que vous dit l'église vous
êtes malade vous est hanté par le démon
sénat fin ça bien de votre naissance
qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est ce qu'elle est
l'argument qu'on vous donne pour vous
dire on va te on va te retirer c'est
tout cette homosexualité il le compare à
quoi exactement pour que ce soit merci
pas tout de suite le démon plus
d'exercice mais plus tard oui mais
plutôt le on va y venir les gens quelque
chose qui nous habite tous une blessure
et qui va m'empêcher puisque j'avais je
vous le répète une sexualité compulsive
qui va m'empêcher de vivre un célibat
une chasteté une continence finalement
et on assiste beaucoup dansé pria de
guérison et de délivrance aussi sur le
côté blessures souffrance de
l'homosexualité est une vulnérabilise à
sion dans le discours qui fait que
finalement on parle pas trop de maladies
en tout cas j'en ai pas le souvenir mais
surtout de blessure de blessures
profondes de souffrance de croire nous
avaient été blessées dont vous êtes
devenu homosexuel on va vous dire nyse
vous ne savez plus voilà et en gros
comme je les dis précédemment beaucoup
de blessures liées à hama relations
intrafamiliales avec ma mère avec mon
père ce qui d'ailleurs a été très long
pour moi de me détacher de deux de ses
de ce formatage parce que vous imaginez
ce que j'ai pu dans ma tête de jeunes
faire porter à mes parents alors
jean-michel comment se passe le
glissement au stade vraiment supérieur
parce que on peut parler d'exorcisme au
sens strict oui vous avez subi un
exorcisme alors bac 1 8 à vrai dire
après sept centres de formation j'ai
rejoint ma séminaire dans le var c'est
parce que j'avais toujours le désir
d'être prête donc j'ai fait des études
de philosophie et théologie là j'étais
assez cadré et ça a été un moment de
répit il y avait quelques de temps en
temps des piles embardée au sauna de
nice ou à lyon là j'avais découvert les
saunas ouais j'avais découvert le
plaisir j'étais cadre est moyennement
alors oui oui il y avait des embardées
comme jeudi et surtout peut-être voyez
eric ce qui a été pour moi assez
terrible dans ma tête c'est que je
commençais à vraiment y prendre du
plaisir donc ça me mettait dans dans un
tourment intérieur terrible la sexualité
passe était ce pas simplement des petits
moments comme ça mais c'était un vrai
moment de plaisir des changes et je me
je me défends des de slam et enfin
pendant ces années quand même il ya eu
des années de répit et puis j'ai rejoint
une petite communauté en fondation comme
il y en avait beaucoup dans la fin des
années 80 et qui ont été beaucoup
aujourd'hui
mis sur le devant de la scène si je puis
dire dramatiquement parce qu'il ya eu un
nombre incalculable d'abus de la part
des fondateurs en particulier mais bon
moi j'ai rejoint une petite communauté
dans le nord du var qui était très
fragile parce qu'elle était petit temps
fondation il y avait une part de ceux
solitude assez important dans cette vie
et la toux mais tourne en sont ressortis
j'ai fugué plusieurs fois pour aller
baiser pardonnez moi d'être vulgaire
j'ai rejoint le sport parce que nous
sommes très choqués bon j'ai rejoint des
lieux de drague je revenais j'étais mal
enfin bon je m'alimente et mal je
dormais mal physiologiquement j'étais
donc fragilisé psychologiquement et les
responsables de cette communauté bien
entendu mon tourment là aussi -
accueillis et puis un jour et passer un
prêtre qui avait une certaine aura
charisme comme on en rencontre est
beaucoup dans les années 80 il se
permettait tous ces gens là parce que il
était directement branché sur l'esprit
saint d'après eux et donc quand on lui a
parlé de mon trouble bas il a dit très
simplement il a posé un diagnostic
immédiat je l'entends encore il a dit
c'est très simple jean michel il est
possédé par le démon de l'homosexualité
et dans l'église il ya une prière pour
cela c'est l'exorcisme avoir consiste un
exercice alors je me serais honoré nous
on en connaît soit les vieilles
histoires ça a l'air de remonter au
moyen âge soit on a vu quelques films
d'horreur mais on en a rarement enfin
à quoi ça consiste alors ça va vous
paraître irréel effectivement comme un
film
pourtant c'est malheureusement est
dramatiquement ce que j'ai vécu et ce
que d'autres personnes continuent à
vivre d'après les témoignages que l'on
reçoit dans notre collectif rien à
guérir donc je me suis retrouvé un soir
dans la petite chapelle magnifique de ce
lieu où nous étions avec un petit groupe
le prêtre étant habillés en habit
sacerdotale avec son aube son étole donc
l'imaginaire bien sûr et est touchée
puisque tout cela est symboliquement
fort et commence la grande prière
d'exorcisme avec l'aspersion d'eau
bénite donc à tous série toute cette
liturgie très cadré même si c'était dans
mon cas un exorcisme sauvage puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas reconnus par l'évêque du
lieu mais il y en avait énormément dans
toute cette mouvance du renouveau
charismatique à l'époque et
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
cette prière est prononcé il va y avoir
une parole qui m'est adressée qui est
adressé à mon corps donc on pas si vous
voulez à une autre étape que les la
prière de guérison ou de délivrance qui
est adressée à dieu ce que vous entendez
par parole qui met bien tout simplement
des monts de l'homosexualité sort du
corps de jean michel et là bas
effectivement je suis fragile je viens
de vous le dire physiologiquement
psychologiquement mon corps réagit je me
met à trembler a écumé a crié à me taper
la tête contre le sol carrelé de la
chapelle et pour les gens qui sont là on
est en plein délire ils se disent bas
effectivement le démo est là et il ya
des paroles qui disent effectivement on
confirme la présence du demo et on part
dans un délire et moi je suis pris là
dedans et ce qui est terrible c'est que
je consens à cela si je suis sous
emprise comme la plupart des emprises
qu'elle soit sexuelle ou ou spirituelle
et bien il ya un inversion de
culpabilité je consens et je vais
accepter dans ce lieu deux exorcisme
je vais tenter de mettre fin à mes jours
après le second exorcisme et finalement
on m'envoie me reposer en suisse à
veysonnaz dans le valais suisse en
dessus de sion chez un prêtre qui
m'accueille là aussi et qui le voit mal
qui voit que j'ai des attaques de
panique et qui va me proposer de
rejoindre une communauté qui était dans
la mouvance du renouveau et là je vais
vivre 5 exorcisme on va me proposer
parce qu'il y avait semble-t-il à un
prêtre qui avait aussi un charisme
particulier des dons particuliers pour
chasser le démon permets moi même
question naïve
quand ces gens qui pratiquent
l'exorcisme sur vous voit que ça ne
marche pas pourquoi en faire deux trois
quatre cinq six et pourquoi s'acharner à
ce point là et bien parce que eric ça va
vous paraître totalement fou mais voyez
on est dans une époque et ça continue
dans beaucoup de communautés
malheureusement j'ai des témoignages
très sérieux où on pense qu'on est à la
fin du monde danser danser mouvement du
renouveau charismatique que le christ va
revenir et que nous sommes nous moi y
compris les apôtres des derniers temps
et donc l'homosexualité fait partie des
grands combats des derniers temps c'est
encore véhiculée dans beaucoup de
communautés aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de
têtes dans beaucoup d'esprits et donc le
démon m'attaque et quelque part ça me
valorise aussi parce que je me dis je
suis un appeau des derniers temps mais
comme ça marche pas que je continue à
avoir des tentations je continue à
regarder des livres porno et c'est là
que je me masturbe que tout ça donc pour
me dis eh bien il faut continuer parce
que le démon s'acharne pas ce que tu vas
vraiment être un apôtre des derniers
temps on est dans la folie parce qu'on
rentre dans ses roues dans
l'obscurantisme oui mais on rentre dans
mon cerveau quelque chose de mensongers
et on m'amène à vivre donc 5 exorcisme
ans fils jeu revient finalement dans le
var et là je suis tellement mal que le
responsable de la communauté me dit j'ai
entendu parler d'un prêtre qui a
vraiment un charisme qui est en lien
avec une voyante qui voit le christ qui
vit sa passion toutes les semaines c'est
dans la région parisienne et on m'amène
donc on part du var avec un des frères
de la communauté j'arrive dans un très
beau presbytère au bord d'une petite
rivière en revanche je n'ai je ne me
souviens plus dans quel département
c'était de la région parisienne c'est un
très beau lieu et on me propose de
monter dans une chambre je suis très
agité et le prêtre préconise que je sois
attaché sur un lit il y avait là
religieux qui était en repos un jeune
religieux un espèce de gros molosse qui
me tient sur le lit et là je vais vivre
un
dernier exorcisme qui va me conduire
dans un épuisement physique et une
violence alors je n'ai pas été violée
physiquement mais mais il ya une hutte
mon corps a été attaché sur un lit je
n'oublie pas les sanglants j'en ai
encore le sommet on est d'accord en plus
du délit on est dans l'illégalité la
plus totale et j'entends toujours ces
mêmes mots c'est même au sort de ce
corps ça tange j'hurle enfin
jeu ce soir comment vous dire que moi je
ne me considère pas comme un témoin mon
histoire elle et elle n'est pas
universelle et les singulières bien
évidemment je n'ai pas rencontré que des
dingues dans l'église dieu merci
autrement je n'y serai plus aujourd'hui
j'y ai rencontré deux magnifiques
personnes et j'en rencontre encore de
magnifiques communauté mais là j'ai
vraiment rencontré des pervers des gens
qui ont abusé de leur pouvoir spirituel
qui ont failli me faire perdre ma santé
psychologique et aussi ma vie est bon
mois mais encore une fois mon histoire
n'est pas universelle je ne suis pas je
me considère pas du tout comme un témoin
chez vous ce soir je viens parce que je
crois qu'il faut parler il faut le dire
et quand je suis revenu dans dans le var
et bien lévesque de toulon joseph madec
à l'époque est prévenu de cela a dit aux
responsables la communauté il faudrait
que jean-michel fasse une cure de
sommeil dans un hôpital psychiatrique ce
club explique psychiatrique pardon mais
on m'a conduit à l'hôpital psychiatrique
de nice et c'est devant les grilles de
l'hôpital psychiatrique de nice que j'ai
retrouvé le plancher des vaches comme on
dit en savoie un certain réalisme un bon
sens de ma famille paysanne et j'ai fui
j'étais rattrapé par un de mes amis qui
ne m'a pas obligé à rentrer parce que je
sentais que si je rentrais là c'était
c'était fini pour moi et je suis parti
et j'ai tout doucement reconstruit ma
vie mais je ne veux pas comme on dit
dans le sud un jeu vient de montpellier
faire le kakou devant vous ce soir la
reconstruction de ma vie elle se
poursuit et je sais que je serai un être
à jamais fracassée et si je veux
exprimer une gratitude aujourd'hui ce
soir à dieu ou à la vie peu importe à
vrai dire c'est une gratitude d'êtres
vivants parce que
merci parce que quand on est passé si
proches de la mort quand on a eu le goût
mortifère non dans le corps et bien
aujourd'hui je goûte chaque instant de
ma vie et voyez bons mots là on est
entouré de lumière et tout ça mais c'est
vrai que la plus belle des lumières
c'est de voir un regard qui qui est
bienveillant sur moi et qui ne me fait
pas peur et des apôtres notre armée
lance j'ai une question fondamentale à
vous poser est ce qu'elle est et
théologique
il y a chez les grands chrétiens du
xxème siècle notamment chez les grands
écrivains deux catégories il ya la
catégorie que j'appellerais celle de
paul claudel pour qui la foi ne peut pas
se passer de l'institution de l'église
des sacrements etc et puis il y en a un
autre que j'adore qui s'appelle charles
péguy qui était tellement effrayée par
l'institution ecclésiastique tellement
effrayée par l'église par sa perversion
sa perversité son dévoiement pas
forcément sexuel mais d'autres
dévoiement l'époque qu'il avait
considéré que la chance qu'on avait
quand on était catholique c'était
précisément de pouvoir avoir un accès
direct au christ sans passer par la
soi-disant maison du christ qui était
fait en fait d une sorte de mafia
pervers en tout genre est ce que vous
pouvez imaginer un moment donné vous
auriez plus obligés d'être chrétien
catholique en dehors de l'église
d'ailleurs comme france 1 françois
d'assise l'afep dans une fraternité
qu'ils y soient laïques s'étaient pas
forcément ecclésiastique nous reste deux
minutes alors moi je je je suis
aujourd'hui adjoint en pastorale
scolaire dans un lycée catholique donc
j'ai une mission nommée vie à un moment
de votre vie je parle pas aujourd'hui
alors un moment de ma vie
peut-être larbi la foi n'est pas dans la
bâtiment mais j'ai toujours été dans un
chalet dire un conflit de loyauté par
rapport à l'institution je crois que je
ne vais pas quitter parce que comme je
disais précédemment j ai rencontré de
belles percées la fois et est de votre
côté avoue l'avresne paris re l'espère
oui enfin en tout cas elle est aussi du
côté de très belles personnes la même
force à l'intérieur j'ai pu rencontrer
de remettre la composition la situe sur
la question laurent gestion des
thérapies de conversion puisque je vais
j'imagine que vous avez beaucoup de
témoignages au delà de l'église en
dehors de l'église puisqu'il en existe
également est-ce que vous avez book est
ce que vous sentez que les tabous
tombent et dans quel autre domaine se
déroulent ces thérapies de conversion
alors c'est pas dans mon domaine de
compétence mais c'est dans le collectif
que nous avons fondé suite au
documentaire d'arte et il y a deux ans
qui a commencé à médiatiser les
thérapies de conversion nous avons des
témoignages aussi dans le cadre de
l'accompagnement ou de soins
psychologiques entre guillemets nous
avons aussi et ça je tiens à le
souligner des personnes qui continuent à
proférer un langage qui vulnérabilise
les personnes quand vous dites un jeune
catholique par exemple dans un camp
scout qui s'ouvrait et que vous lui
dites mais tu sais tu ne seras jamais
heureux en étant homosexuel tu ne
pourras pas vraiment aimé c'est l'amour
de soi l'homosexualité c'est le triomphe
de l'égoïsme c'est vulnérabiliser les
personnes et c'est cela ça fait le lit
des thérapies de conversion le discours
obscurantisme le la lecture
fondamentaliste des textes et ce
discours e vulnérabilise ans si je puis
dire entre guillemets et bien font le
lit des thérapies de conversion